the button addict let me know if you see
agree on your side sweets or out start
no my side yeah it's good to know rhymer
and we are live welcome to the islands
podcast and the Lords of gaming dotnet
episode number 145 and it's another day
another good day we're back at the round
table the Lord's date I'm very excited
about all our special guests and we've
got Phil Spencer's new competition Rod
Fergusson leaving the coalition dan
Houser leaving rock star and the sobel
studios to talk about so we gonna get
right into it
I want to introduce four ladies of the
RAM who not only provide a breath of
fresh air to the monotony of most gaming
podcasts but also provide a positive
atmosphere with a mature female
perspective
introducing the creators and host of the
grown women gaming podcast our favorite
ladies of Destiny and the stars of every
III rooftop party
Callie Georgia Washington and now VA
while making their debut into the realm
of the Lord's my girls lady infamous
l-boogie Delilah HD and Charisse grown
women gaming how you doing over dude had
to get y'all in the road the collabo the
Rebs are united this will go down with
you and what you've been playing yeah
I've been playing in South Park
fractured but whole I know right if I'm
trying to like a game
I mean classy she's something else um
I've been on that call of duty modern
warfare grind in photos I love my
shooters and I played a couple PC games
like Gary smart
with trouble with cheating you never
knew it was very like reactions to like
people leaving the JMO series exit to
afternoon gents and ladies happy Lord's
Day salute salute you what you've been
playing Oh
Mortal Kombat trying to learn how to
play with Joker and Sindel she just
popped up and I am sucking with both
right now I got into that fancy start
online yesterday you got in well well
not crazy not Friday I got in yesterday
morning early at like 6:30 got on his
seven and I play so I got to level 20
Wow I was there for if you're the
insider program apparently you'll be
able to get them both anyway yeah yeah
yeah I mean I'm loving it it's so
nostalgic like I swear it's off my is oh
I have a blaster this game any drops
yeah yeah but then also I got the plant
division and this okay there we go back
it back in the side of the desde el bugs
would you be playing apex apex
I gotta make a video because like the
day before my birthday my birthday I
probably got like 10 wins between the
two days and they are slit with it I was
a new character so most people are
trying to grab him up but then don't
utilize him yeah he's pretty awesome he
can move really quickly when he's
crouched because he's Bionic so you know
no muscles and he has this ability where
he basically turns off everyone else's
ability is also able to agree I could
see a lot of people that really focus on
[Music]
people don't use able to pull up a tune
or a totem and you put it up and you die
it brings you right back to the totem
okay right so you created your own spawn
point almost right so you have to hold X
to enable it so if everyone isn't around
you when you do it and they don't enable
it then they don't get to use it gotcha
then you also have to place it in a
right place because we found out that if
you shoot it while someone else is using
it they all die everyone's made things
very interesting very interesting
apex low and that's what's yeah shout
out the respawn they really come in with
the Lord
yeah they come away and I see the
Hammond technology a little Titan dances
away yes
cited for titanfall 3 because they're
like really like integrating the two now
good that's what I want to hear it gives
me hope
now we just need a titanfall actual yes
and he can shut me up back stop
complaining I wanna write one of them
one of them to pilot it in one of the
agents one of the heroes or wherever
they grow them I don't know I'm asking I
can't remember if one of them is a pilot
or not yeah I'm not sure
Ilana what you've been playing oh um so
I too haven't played the Pennsy Star
Online 2 close believe it is Friday I
was able to get in so that's pretty nice
I also got to level 40 and from there I
kind of I was playing straight so I
crashed real hard sleep that desti to my
ex cloud and it also times dinner of
course that's right ladies it around but
of course they can cuff of course you
get the four horsemen ILP so you already
know I got my co-host co-host my brother
from another mother the difficult game
Conqueror Lord of reviews and the house
of the young wolf mommy
Lord addict I do sir I'm doing pretty
good I woke up about 20 minutes ago
normally I like today I woke up looked
at my phone I was like it does not say
12:30 cuz I like a little time you know
relax podcast uh I gotta get straight up
out of bed into this Google hangout man
someone was a link Blasi that's what
that room yeah I played that Dark
Crystal man to like seven
you talk about the tactics right you
talk about like stuff like the messenger
I can say too much because you know you
might you might be you might drive down
here over the bed of course returning
our most technical gaming Lord the solo
player who lives with a single player
selfish experience and also the sastra
Damas mr. Flamm profile Illuminati and
lower-paid short of the iron bank
mom-in-law sovereign sir what's going on
y'all what's going on I have returned to
the round despite all these jokes about
you know coronavirus corn you know
working hard yeah I play any Star Wars
this week which is making me mad cuz
that Star Wars
shut up yeah I'll be sad for some reason
again oh let's play some switch so
mm-hmm
I got back in his older because I never
played the DLC man you start playing
older and that's just a whole nother
rabbit hole and you just I was on it so
I played that having fun with that and
actually I got on the the g-force now
okay I haven't actually gotten to play a
game yet Coco it is it is definitely not
as easy up front to get your games up
and running so the whole the whole idea
behind g-force now is that you basically
you're playing your games that you own
already right so that's one thing that
it where differs from X cloud whereas
there's no actual service that you're
playing games that you don't wouldn't
normally have access to correctly it's
your games that you own whether on Steam
epic game store or oh I believe also the
Ubisoft store something like that and
they have their own store exactly sold
right you can purchase it directly
delete but beyond that it's not
something on the surface you can just
play one second so I forgot def sitting
with the files of a chat suspect uno was
the way they suspect
uno was the wave catch kunas concert
it's a full-blown anime concert everyone
needs to check out I don't know that a
shout out to suspect who don't continue
though oh so that's cool but at the same
time there's nothing just on the service
you can just try out right you have it
has to be something in it because when
you log in you have to log into that
service to access the game it'll take
you to the epic game so it'll take you
to steam to log in and then you're going
through there right so I try to do it on
my lap my laptop's I'm connected to it
you know how hard line Ethernet I want
to try it that way first so it's telling
me first of all um so let me I said let
me go into Arkham City so if you're on
your laptop through GeForce now it asks
you to download the game I'm like that's
not the purpose of the car why did
asking me to download the game like I
lay it on the service oh yeah that's
something that needs to be rectified
because if you're if whatever you're
doing is on the direct device you're
using and it's gonna ask you I mean if
it's a computer it's gonna ask to
download at local which is ridiculous
so then I try to do it on my phone right
they have a g-force now for the Android
try to do that I get in there it loads
it up whatever load down with the app
whatever it tells me well this game was
not made to work with controllers you
have to go in and set up the config yes
Batman Arkham City mmm love the flavor
controllers there's no issues playing PC
though man what you talking about I
don't even hear none of this ridiculous
ridiculous low moan at you say you're
not feeling it - he said it's only
valuable if you're a big PC gamer yeah
that really I mean back there the stuff
that you own already is fantastic but
these initial hoops to get to your games
and then just the quality of life stuff
like wow how do you not recognize I have
a controller connected issues that
you're having because I play with them
petruchio exactly difficult kid if
you're playing with the proprietary
machines or whatever like the shield's
it plays flawlessly recognizes all of
that and yeah then when you take it off
of their proprietary stuff and you go to
something else that's what I'm hearing
issues coming because as soon as they
said that the the GeForce now psycho
came upstairs and I can turn my stuff on
and see what's up and I didn't have to
do the downloads I didn't have to do
none of that stuff I just turned it on
and then they have this like this beta
system where you can play their games
right so you can go in but you're
streaming their games so the streaming
is like this seamless this great is
fantastic especially on new shows what
it was telling me was that it was not
allowed I already set up for the for
whatever the founders thing right I set
up you get three months free and in
addition to that with the founders
that's where you can access r-tx games
which is what I really want to see right
so the thing about that is that unless
you actually own that on one of these
other on either you know on either steam
or epic or whatever lets you own it it's
not letting you just stream it even to
test it it's not gonna let you
which is crazy so if you're telling me
that through shield it's different then
that that's yes unlike something
Microsoft these things box down use it
is not in do is that mean I'd a but it's
like let me just real quick cuz my
stress is different to but I've been
using it with um you know obviously bike
my galaxy phone remotely I'm tryin
destiny on it or and it's the PC version
of destiny and man it was super
impressive it was like sixty frames it
was it was it now we'll say this the
interface to get to the game was wonky
then I did have a problem that Chi BOTS
who had to fix that it wouldn't
recognize my arm Xbox one controller
like it would recognize it but like the
analog functionally wasn't working like
it's like I was when I started the game
my character was just spinning around
looking at the ceiling and I was like
what is going more like so i no matter
what i changed it control so there's
definitely I feel you saw there's some
type of controller interface problem and
we're getting to the game ain't really
simplistic once you get it to work it's
fire and what makes our podcast so we
were say before the park and we got so
much but that's where they just g-force
issues yeah yeah and sin robbed good for
you and of course we have this a que the
access game the Lord of combat sports
king of the statues who demands nothing
less to their premium experience it is
the leader of the fraud alert movement
ooh
beloved Lord King how you doing sir you
know what I'm doing whoa my god so
listen last night before the fight even
happen right I'm sorry yes
I said you know something feels off
about this fight I think Jones Kalu's
right so when the fight is on I think
was round one quote with a jab too
swollen um I don't know it was he was
just oh I don't even know how to help me
out the decision be honest with you I
saw oh boy it was like a mirror of
himself but younger right and but not as
good because bones his prime is
incredible and what what cogs telling me
is he can't get up pause for these dudes
that really don't move his meal yeah and
I can understand that but at the same
time that's how you get caught slipping
and I thought yesterday oh boy got
caught slipping yeah yeah it was it was
listen I mean I had rounds one through
three two raises yes now yes four or
five bones one and the wrestling but
even even soul you know do was getting
back up
I think where dude hurt himself in the
judges I was that in the fifth round I
think he really was he was just survived
and Conor never been a 10-8 round and
that could have been I think that would
hurt him but one judge was bugging they
had it like for round one oh I can't I
can't get down with that type of time
but no I feel you it was a good fight
though aren't they bit yeah
it was a good fight at bows he
definitely came on strong like to see
the rematch I don't know what's going on
but I I agree with you
yeah so when you tell them I'm moving up
Madison Square Garden doing that ain't
gonna work with them visit when the
Gondor numbers well that's not hit he's
gonna fight somebody
they're very tailor-made for him and
heavyweight gonna be his last fight but
what he did was he got the 14 in a row
his joint was solidified there alright
so going on to heavyweight he's gonna
get those big bucks when it comes to
Madison Square Garden hopefully we can
go watch the fight and I honestly think
that's it for them after
oh oh yeah that part was finding me that
part felt like Wolfenstein that was
fantastic it was I know you would like
this deston off' occasion of the game
the best part about it is it's not
Wolfenstein played and it is great
there's a couple of glitches but all in
all it's a anyway like crazy super it's
like Esther just walks in just like
I wasn't gonna buy it anyway
[Laughter]
anyway he allow me to save my baby just
yet it try to get into phantasy start
online I gotta talk about that gwg we
gotta talk about something
being domine but it's predominantly men
and women of color on this panel
[Laughter]
like no no listen he's from West
Virginia he black I do you stride about
the character creating options the skin
tone options or lack thereof it should
be more representation for my skin tone
because I did see you can change it
darkens you wanted it but it was just
that they didn't have the facial feature
options like I was gonna say because I'm
like what they're trying to say is that
they are mixed babies alright and babies
are actually mixed with you know Asian
and you know and there you go anime
understand unfortunately that's the
standard out them beat disrespect slow
my eyes I don't think like that jet the
Japanese like I don't think they really
care about stuff like that cuz I feel
like a lot of like their games
particularly have that issue and they're
just like deal with it I had the same
issue with um with astral train and I
wonder it yeah it wasn't enough very
maybe maybe it's just cuz like their
culture don't see that too often like I
yeah I agree with you because when you
go over there as a black person maybe
like like you live in a zoo like are you
doing
that's what I say obviously the g-force
bail
rock it out for a little bit it's
definitely there and of course
definitely getting my fractal line on
Imperium foundation tribute Bay because
Charles is coming back it's gonna be lit
next season saw right away okay well be
nothing I watched your market with you
in the bonta's did you maximize it yeah
did you go down to all your little
towers yeah when they put all the front
leaving the joists on my residence rank
is high it creates more fractal mean
week to week joint and all I mean is
it's good what what I feel is I felt a
lot of people aren't watching on the
last word and I think they actually did
watch the last word didn't understand
how the fracking works a lot of people
hit me into dams like you could you play
destiny you need to know it I'm with the
last word just my opinion appreciate all
that straight now we got a blaze through
this real quick we got to pay the bills
but he unfortunately did not pay the
bills last week armed solve his back I'm
bankers beg so I'm gonna take care of
this real quick yes sir we're gonna run
to our patrons and say thank you to
everyone really appreciates we'll do our
patrons patreon patrons first and then
of course our YouTube subscribers
so first up course or je meds thank you
so much my brother then we have the
forever patron Lord Cory lydic over the
nominate you file please say Congress
partially light-skinned we left our
patron then we got Lord slow-mo back
slap by HB 33 yes Lord intended errect
what QX seven masters Excel or novocaine
novocaine get at me please I still owe
you t Spring has not answered me let's
do this buddy
yes sir then we have Lord fastback 67 or
68 LLG Lord stitch 66 69 no switch
topics you're lucky today then we have
look back abode oh thank you so much
Lord gaming Forte by Undead 3x and we
had Lord lynchpin my lord Elliott
slimovitz
oh le ah here he gets busy lawyer and
our newest patron or seafood poetic ex
initiative thank you so much and we got
the wall of better Lord Sammy Prescott
and of course chocolate by himself
flip-flop yes sir Lord of the stream
team North's now dope yes my lord kobera
thank you so much as several doses are
addict drop to a picture I'll link in
the chat followed by Lord now sweetie
that's vici yes we gave you the fight
talk times me cheating yes next up Lord
Jameson aka j-rock that's right round
favorite reviews and last but not least
of course our brother from across the
pond Lord death singer sings sorry I
said you the links in the chat versus
the pages get these prizes right oh we
gotta go to our YouTube subs thank you
so much our newest subscriber so thanks
so much first up we have Lord bed stars
finance Thank You slow bottle by filly
eagle yes and we have the blue one
yes woman
we'll listen the letter gotta get back
to work thank you brother much
appreciated and we have no phantom
cracking okay Joe hands oh you sleepy
Goblin too deep I love them music game
by choice
oh that's my favorite Lord which gang
Noir is gonna pay off there's no payoff
then we have north Jonathan be that's
funny then we have G pick so big salute
once again a double dipper thank you so
much Lord game before take what a
tech-talkin to building 150 by please
myself
thank you for that's right shout out to
the Kelly team forte is in the compound
baby we have the king of the stream team
north now know once again double dipper
thank you will help ease a little
restored Hades thank you man so have nor
titus right thank you so much we have an
original iron Lord Lord 0 io guy shot
the clutch Mabel to to lhasa chat have a
great show with gwg no captain game past
intro to start up we definitely do yeah
I might go adding on that continue
give me some superhero music for that
one yeah especially these guys are here
trying to shame me
filled it for me yeah I'm Lord tempest
Sun baby for the support of saloon
double-dipping again our brother from
across the pond Lord of Empires death
singer himself let's get into these
giveaways back to the community let's
give it back Oh miss Ted I'll give card
giveaway is the first one I do and it
goes to Lord Fastback success bang this
was self as back yes sir yes sir please
get at me in the DMS or for yes yes
what's right $20 gift card giveaway
Iliad [ __ ]
what they know with his rig that sounds
[Laughter]
really please reach other cell with a
win over be sure to reach out to solver
about yours yes yes please please um
yeah listen man maybe some need to
really stop and think about how open
that bag is being dropped off Bank needs
to be greased that's a new problem
[Laughter]
waiting all day to say that
Wow Oh awesome chat just the stitch cog
my son javi just turned four is he old
enough for me to get him to switch yet
please explain thoroughly the Bostick do
I you know what you're Jameson I think
you're onto something
hahaha I think you need to get him maybe
that switch like you know say and it
should give you some good advice on what
games to get me he's a kind of sore this
can tell you everything about the switch
exactly well knows what games are on you
knows everything about that platform you
like that more than I do
I know we keep Baba but this way what's
good a big winner
okay nutty spring let's go to our tee
spring giveaway giveaway if they say rig
can we like rescinding gonna cost more
than whatever you got to get yo yo
salute damn you know that's what's up
now you can put the phone right away so
yeah thank you guys for all your support
on both phones we really appreciate it
again go to that patreon supporters
there if you guys want to support us on
YouTube hit that subscribe button at the
bottom of the stream it's right there
you get all your Mochis you pocket watch
all you want yeah oh and then the fact
they'll be going to packs you're going
to have our video you can have early
access to all our videos that we'll be
putting up I'm just looking at
our calendar and oh boy we're gonna be
having three teams running remember
we're all media subscribers know what
they would have a ton of stuff to look
at we're going to be uploading daily and
we might have a little treat for you
guys as far as giving you our
impressions like at least one of those
days you're gonna get a short podcast
get our impressions on what we see what
we like and stuff that you should be
looking out for subscribe to the patreon
today wow thank you so much really
appreciate good stuff out the way
finally what the laws have been playing
I want to start with the ladies of grown
women gaming so I'm both Anana I think
both l-boogie and Delilah's kind of sort
of treatment before I think l-boogie was
on episode 81 and diluted with
roundtable with the stream team don't
like harm you a lie he got a list of
everything okay so we got a $5 super
chair from stitch if you want to give
him out problems let him hit him a
switch for 20 and 720p really hurt those
eyes also make sure he uses Sun
Ivica do you know what kit kognito
didn't you know what stitch you're onto
something I completely agree with you
that's blood right there we go mover so
like I said we got those histories so I
wanted to focus on two ladies in the
room I don't know as much about what
their video game system history so start
with Lady infamous and Lady Charisse
first and I want to start off lady
infamous what was some of the first
video game systems you had and what kind
of got you into gaming know what I grew
up not only one going to other people
houses and enjoying the fast to join the
games and when my mom finally got me
when it was the Nintendo the original
Tendo when black and grey she gave me a
couple of game boys I said a couple
cousins yes a couple my access to the
with the first that's what you tell your
parent like it was him you got to point
them out to the thank you so many more
the more we get the more emojis we give
you also thank you
continued lady if I got to hear about
this Game Boy story continue okay no no
I mean just multiple Gameboy um let her
down the line I grew up like once in
arcades and I was a stay by the mall the
mall had a movie theaters moving the
earth the movie theater you had an
arcade on me all day plan every cut
every arcade stand I could find and you
know I couldn't afford to have one of my
own and I'm like a full-grown adult now
oh I went to got me up guys Xbox 60
I mean I two copies with two games one
almost call of duty modern warfare
mm-hmm Dante's Inferno and
now yeah I have like the ps4 the Xbox
the PC in the switch so I'm the I'm
blessed I'm blessed
that's what sucks you come full circle
she's like go out buddy get to that
point when I'm alone all these consoles
you know you always see me playing call
of duty
put me all definitely just one that now
has me like kind of like sometimes I
don't wanna play that's me but this
sometime I want to and then when I do
play I already know I'm gonna be in the
room definitely the members you know hit
these people we got fun emojis we sit
dog I see it like everything like
everything I play are you like but at
least if I try you know ease its
I can try lot of rich history a lot of
very distant so ladies sharise's get you
going what was some of the first video
game systems you had what got you to
gave me yes she was like here you
basically sit to yourself so much here's
an NES complaint the bombs yeah my boss
who likes you so we used to play
together Tetris and Mario Yoshi on
Sunday morning
[Laughter]
we came out and my mother took me in my
friend when it came to what it was it
was an M rating I think it was it was
more Owen I think was more but I'll
never forget I had my cousin because I
was like 15 or something at the time bye
and she is she you know she didn't
really like buying him raise gaze your
thing I'll never forget like cuz
normally going there is never really say
nothing they're just okay here's your
game I musta got like that Oh tight dude
cuz he was like you know this is rated M
and I've seen that the new snitchin at
the table and there's like you know like
well that was that was fun I guess I'm
not quite there and she's like she's
like no it's fine nothing okay I'm good
he's like using reason I just want a
shout out to Philly Eagle fight on a
super chat shout out to the full Spig I
could relate that's what's up salute so
kitties high school time I kind of
stopped playing because you know life
got in the way if people told me that
girls could play video games now replay
yeah my boys like that more and I was
like yeah
baby you got boobs they're not gonna
care if you play video games I was like
[ __ ] I saved my money after college
some kind of got it in the Xbox the
original that's right that was the best
decision that you did we got at all Wow
I mean never I'm gonna let then why are
you disgruntled with it because you
don't have no like no ties to it so yeah
so if you like had a PlayStation 1 or
Playstation 2 or sometimes to it then
you'll probably have a different feel
for and if you play multiplayer games
and stuff like like there was nothing
that one title during the Playstations
about Final Fantasy 7 nothing ever mood
you say you know what I might want to
check this out real quick
Charice about way to cause together we
played with was Xbox Oh
like Xbox so I understand why think
about it I remember my mom when I was
like 11 or 12 or something like that she
got some money back from my dad and I'm
convincing her to stop awestruck because
I knew I was about to talk to the woman
or buying me a shot at the kick Jason
tell what's going on everyone epic show
right here salut salut so did she so you
leave it you finally in the Sony
ecosystem with the PlayStation 4 though
there was something to play would you
pick up spider-man what's the one
horizon zero dawn
you're working you know what King Betty
I think you're onto something
he says shout out to Charisse Xboxes to
pack all the games right there like
honestly PlayStation weird [ __ ] Eddie
any person could ask from gwg is flora
some crow women gaming the movement and
just like coming together like how did
that whole process store any one of you
guys could answer lady yeah that would
be me let's go um like five six years
ago I just got my sister on and I wanted
to look for content creators in color
you know I'm saying and I saw some you
know and I'm like you know we got some
gamers out here but then I like where
the ladies at go hmm so um I first saw
Rena the Beast on Twitch and she was
like a called Doody streamer and I'm
like yeah that's like that's something
that that I'm trying to get into so as I
started being a content creator I said
you know what I need to find a space
that grown women can be able to have
this face and play video games and to be
themselves and it was just me at the
beginning and when I started to pitch
this idea to females in in like the
social media aspect of who I know and
who they were who they know I'll be
honest with you some son was witty but
wasn't fully committed son was like and
didn't fit the demographic that I was
looking for
I wanted people genuine that love
videogames and passion at places if you
can kick it at I'm patient you know um I
first met up first it was l-boogie old
208 well she found me through a modern
grown man gaming okay pick me out and
then we started doing grown them in game
nights on Fridays okay so we used to
play battlefield used to play Call of
Duty we used to play Friday 13 to play
destiny and then um I knew I knew the
Lila for a minute
and I and she wanted me to step my game
up on it interested and I was like I got
you no problem if I can understand I
move the line before but I know no BS
time female so she's not gonna be
associated with a name attached to
something unless yeah I feel that good I
was like mr. Hart's heart like hardcore
PlayStation you know hit each at so when
you said that he all love affair without
the window with you the frogs
oh shut the Frog files even chat that's
was so ultra reset podcast in the
building shout out to the gaming Suge
Knight kick and take me don't always
agree with you gaming talk but your
combat talk is always on point hey late
awesome thank you brother
much love a salute to the team yeah
Cyrus he said did anyone call it the Ori
and wasteland see II I don't know what
that see champion edition it's really
called the champion edition yeah they're
running I thought it was free fire to
see he was champion edition but I don't
play fighters I don't know anything
about oh yeah that will explain me
busting your butt but I mean obviously
if I don't play
I mean lady so use like [ __ ] Teresa's
like I'm coming that's resolved Delilah
was like look you got it working so what
I did with me and l-boogie we started
doing like game nights first and then
movie and Delilah and we started the
first episode of girl who game it on TRG
okay Megan oh yes yes um so after that
we moved from grg so our own individual
is grown when we gave a channel on
YouTube and we just pushed everything
there our girls on that rock I I could
never ask for for a group of girls like
them and now mrs. me I'll be like we
were constructed the show I was hardcore
you know I really wants to get her in on
this show well I felt like she played
weak when I do I was at that point in my
life I was trying to get things together
running around a lot and so much made
sure I had somebody that I knew that was
authentic and was really about these
games because the biggest thing is we
wanted to make sure that we were
targeting like a hardcore crowd a lot of
people have a perception of women play
games like casuals like no we really do
this so let me guess recent here and so
everybody's clicked speak for herself on
this what was coming into it like what
was your feeling you know not when it's
what she became a part of it with the
lion didn't have me now buggy and lady
like how was your feeling on that coming
together initially out scared is I don't
know what I've never done a podcast
before I've never done anything
like I've been I could give that mystery
I mean playing games now almost I don't
know 20-something odd years if not more
um in my local community I'm I help with
I see problems but I've never been on a
larger scale such as this and so Delilah
takes me out of the blue she's like hey
can't you do Friday I know what day it
was and I was like sure what are we
doing like I'm here good and let's go I
respect
I love I love what you guys said about
you know just didn't wanna you know go
half in you wanna go all the way and
then the thing is I love the hardcore
aspect because dispelling that whole
myth that you know these girls ain't
playing these games like y'all give BL
our time so I know LG's beso is good
it's so cool to see that hardcore
aspects of length no one can't question
that authenticity your challenges
[Music]
you still salty because I wax them right
now we only those citrus peel to our
chests shout to sega and Dominic Spencer
for getting the fill of the fantasy snow
all want to beta underway this weekend
from bumpy start but got those servers
up eventually fantasy store line is back
baby
Oh tonight Michael merci last week our
my brother my 80s nostalgia in the
building so he just went to property and
say hi great show iron Lords grant upper
our talking at Streets of Rage talk
that's what's up and frog a game to our
super chat it's great to see women black
women game especially black with the
game that's the loop ask this next
question um this was actually gonna be
for L because I know everybody had you
one last time we kind of hinted at this
and I wanted to talk about like nerd
culture like back in the game highlight
it wasn't cool right but like it wasn't
cool to be talking about this you had to
hide yet it was like a secret society so
like tell me how you feel about that
stigma now like where where you think we
all right now is gamers I mean I love
that like market is in the other room
right now playing like healing the boys
like you're not doing it right you know
like there's no like well you are
supposed to be here like I love that
we're at least at that point where it's
not a stigma this is not a girl
quote-unquote action you know like so
I'm pretty excited at where we're headed
I think that you know especially with
more of us ladies getting into the
industry and you know more people
calling for you know more diverse
we're you know we're on the right track
definitely definitely
well yeah everybody else agreed they
like what you feel about that just
enough for us to like my house it's
still my family oh yeah my sister's they
don't gave my brother you know it is a
game so it's it's still kind of like you
still play she's like don't you want to
get like you know like a stand to block
this people don't have to see that oh
you my cousin playing video games ain't
you about 30-something
I'm like my god it's like I need you to
get married I need you have why you know
she always be making fun of me over it's
just so great cuz it's like you would
think we've come such a long way with
the way games of like permeated pop
culture and stuff like that but to hear
you guys say it kind of threw me back
like wow cuz like for me is like this is
what I do so if you ain't made me kick
have a discussion all the time y'all get
it out the wages they say friends cuz
it's like this is what this is so much a
part of my life that I try I think it's
mainly like the older generation that
don't understand the game thing cuz like
my mom understands it but like no thing
above my mom's generation to understand
see I'm gonna find that to be true
because a fan fest last year I had this
older dude that was then I know
if he was there he understand he was he
was like my beacon of me like super oh
because he had to be at least 80 years
old and ain't no in awe of yes he was
that's what's up and I was soaking all
of this man and I said man I talked my
way from he's like yeah I'm from
Wisconsin and I won and I was like wow
this is so amazing and I'm looking at
him like you know what
against all odds he was him mm-hmm
against all odds anybody does saying
something to him he was him and you're
gonna have to live in your truth I don't
care like when we go to these shows we
make people we are all together because
I remember us being hugging this school
in the corner and I and I wasn't on that
section I was with the cool kids that
was playing you know that disrespect
game to the Nerds right until one day it
was to do with the with the game boy and
I'm never gonna forget that day I was
like you know what at home I'm playing
games in the closet yeah so he has the
gumption to stand outside and play
outside I could stick up for my homie I
don't know do but I gotta stick up for
him and from there I was like that was
it I don't get a noise when people like
judge me for playing games that don't
understand me or don't know me what
annoys me is when people judge me for
playing certain games like Kingdom
Hearts just like I've been playing this
game for years like it's can't Mickey
Mouse in it but you know it is Dobby
that's a good point
Eddie because what I think we talked
about this on gwg but I was guested on
you got show and it's like people in
this day and age just can't learn to
agree to disagree or just say hey that's
something that you enjoying that's cool
my thing genre me is that she little
person the John remain called me to like
we love turn-based games and I get
clowned on it all the time mmm oh sure
we'll be hooded Twitter so you said when
we were younger gamers with just one
step above the kids that play Dungeons
and Dragons in the school
I got one even worse than that I used to
play yugioh it was even worse than that
because like people understood games to
a point but they're like but you know
cuz of the you kyoka anime people acted
like it was it was even worse why you
play that children's card game think
about people like prepare yourselves to
people who LARP hmm okay gamers they
play all of the same categories like you
know what you know if you ever cosplay I
want you to cosplays a dude named
Thunder off a fable mods of this head
out of jail he said my sister plays
games too she plays ps4 only sadly
specific about living the dream
obviously you know a lot of us you know
a lot of gamers you know dreams kind of
work in the indie game industry and you
you kind of so um you don't have to put
all your business out if you don't want
to but um at the end of day I just
wanted to know like from you you know
working in the game industry some of the
challenges and then also for like people
who want to attain that dream like what
advice could you kind of give them well
it's because like I actually answered
this a couple weeks ago so what I would
tell people is if you're really serious
about being in gaming it's like three
major things you should do no primary
thing is have a great portfolio
it just makes something it doesn't have
to be the best thing at all but just
make something make sure you keep any
connections that you make when you go to
these events really tight oh yeah
I don't know this but I've been part of
since 2007 so it's been a long time
coming for me um and so that's part of
it also know how to walk the walk and
talk the talk like it's not like I just
woke up one day and was like oh yeah now
we're here so it took time I mean I had
to get degrees to go to school and learn
and build stuff and create so but now
it's great the transition has been a
little bit challenging because like
being from Georgia and then having to
Washington the weather differences
people are different it's just it's just
new and so that part's bit tough but I
mean yeah it's fine I'm enjoying the
work that I'm doing there's some things
we can stack and so yeah I mean people
every day and being on the other side of
the spectrums because like you really
get to see all the moving parts there's
so many moving parts you you all have no
idea it's interesting that well you
think that no one's listening to you
guys on like YouTube then be careful
it's all I gotta say
we got a catch gotcha I'll get Lord
Jameson with the nine hours ten hours of
a chat got a run looking forward to
catching the rest lady later ladies and
gents are crushing it as usual salut um
guess solving sovereign god veto
breaking news Alex Jones just confirmed
from reliable insiders that Google and
Amazon and the joint venture cooked up
the coronavirus to the day literally
yesterday I was in and out listening to
a podcast on remember podcaster was and
so what could see I thought it was two
separate
super chanson both he was in there
and he did it a couple times of my my
how much money they spend on this one
we got a deaf singer with the five
pounds of a job he said we had no shame
in school walking around with our
pokemon cards and gay boys strutting
through the school I got clowned on way
more for playing yugioh than I ever did
playing in the setup video so we got a
$10 to the chat from Philly Eagles
I personally trust gamers more than I
trust alcoholics cowards
okay projects their fears into other
people having problems with my hobbies
is gaming is that you problem other
opinions don't cut me any chest checks
it's not spectrum when you look at
family members you like you know I love
and respect you get from your heart you
know it's just ya know moving and
shaking and this question last question
I got is for Cherise I want to talk to
her it refers to obviously it is
February so I wanted to talk to you
specifically just a reference to like
the state of the industry where we are
as far as gaming representation how do
you feel things are you feel things are
getting better and then just obviously
our content creators of color what you
think things are not respected as well I
think things are getting better they
compared at least since I'm now paying
more attention to them
they are getting better and I do it I
don't know how to support it properly
there it is getting better but it could
be better it could be read better we um
especially for females we don't as much
credit for the things that we do and we
have and err to a lot of people to
actually get the credit that we do get
and it shouldn't really be like that we
should it should be on our merits alone
but if you don't look a certain way if
you don't have the right attitude you do
not get the same consideration that some
folks do that make sense I want to say
anything
and I'm not like um as far as like
content creators and stuff like that
wait where do you feel I know obviously
like I came across you guys podcast I
was like wow this is dope you know I I
don't I don't really see this Suzanne
like panel and women of color which I
feel is don't like where do you feel we
are we making strides in that and God
you still we still alone are no I don't
think we're long ways are we are making
stripes again like this we've been doing
this now with years now almost it's not
longer we are there we've had plenty
women of color panel people on women on
our show we find more if anybody you
know but some people just don't they
still like if they they have to I guess
dog share the credit on the forms or
whatever but I noticed and i lurk a lot
i tell you this even in our own little
chat i lurk a lot it's like you you
can't help anybody in this you feel like
that person's gonna help you like you
can't just help somebody out of goodness
your heart that's unheard of in this in
this field is your nothingness question
joy all the ladies could you I gotta ass
shot is now this is just my observation
correct me if I am wrong right like the
way I look at it sometimes kick is like
mobile wait you don't say like FC lie
came out or like really typical like
always gotta be one Queen you listen
like bunnies love a sri suta so it's
like I think it's like do you encounter
issues with other female consecrates
like as far as working together or you
think that's overblown and for more most
is it an ego like I want I wanna get on
Nicki Minaj track I don't mess look
what's going on now I need the dirt
sometimes we feel we encounter where we
were smaller i'ma beat for myself well
we were smaller coming up it felt like
unless they were on our level or lorica
like no one were the hires of social
subscriber count' with health i felt
yeah you right it came down to even
people you know you have a ton in common
with who you ain't only be a great guess
and it was just like damn like they
won't give us a shot like we cool just
like you so it was very rich i want to
know like all you guys encountering that
with other oh yeah wow i mean so yeah
absolutely you could just look at
subscriber count' I mean the people
always they make these assumptions that
we don't have guys on the show we've had
guests on our show men male/female
different races everything so it's one
of those things where people have this
perception and once they build that it's
hard to break out of kind of like death
by perception right um so yeah maybe
deal with it people they just think you
say people are get in their little
bubble they don't challenge some talk
you don't want to reach out you feel
like you're not big enough you know like
you there yet all the same level yet
that's part of it
but yeah I don't understand that whole
concept of not helping each other that
that's always kind of but sometimes you
can't go to everybody show like oh and
it's Saturday sometimes you look at
twitch right and you see female gamers
there I don't consider them real gamers
right
I'm going to tell you which ones I don't
call real gamers all right now at the
same time I'm telling you me and L play
pub G so that's a real gamer she's a
real gamer when I'm talking about this
defeat gamers is you a minute in the
tube top for likes and stuff like that I
don't I don't want to be associated with
that so that's something that stuff
right there I can't respect that part
right um but I do respect the the the
women gamers who actually game like the
Street Fighter game is and stuff like
that who play off of their merits who
get their accolades off of their of
their accomplishments they actually play
games opposed to doing the streaming
stuff that's risque right you know so a
lot of times you know these guys get it
confused and then when they see that you
can actually really play it's a whole
different level of respect you know
because I swear when when we are playing
and deaf singer runs off on his own
little tangent and leaves us alone and
is me L and fuzzy and we're actually you
know struggling out and we have to wait
for death to come back it's nice to know
that L is considered just a gamer yes
not a female gamer you understand what
I'm saying like a gamer so it's a huge
difference and I understand the barriers
that y'all have to go across because a
lot of times guys see a girl in the
channel there are changes so they find
out you female it's like the mood change
it's hard it's it's gotten so bad in
party chats before I'm like dude she's a
chick she's not an alien go next door
knock on the door there's probably a
woman in there
we make the assumption I do have a
question for you all has B you know
being gaming being up today doing
podcast we please ever interfere before
relationships and stuff like that so we
we don't play together which is kind of
weird but we were data and we were
playing man like I'm thinking and it
pissed me off so bad like don't let me
let me be like I wanna don't let me play
if he would just beat you the first time
you call for you really want me to
like it's like my emotions and then you
blew me out of a scam it's like are you
gonna let it be like it is defense yeah
can't have it both ways like that we
don't play together but he's play games
with Apex like play with sharee sometime
like is it strictly because you know
where it could go competitively oh yes
so I don't want to be like go to sleep
at night let me tell real quick now why
is it you came out Rock which is some
competitive game I gotta hear this
let's go to well because like if like oh
my god like I don't know if you ever
like watch me play I get like in the
zone right and I play with stitch in a
tournament and they would let you know
if you are not pulling your weight I
feel like if aren't because especially
with you know how they do the girls and
whatnot if I am getting kills and I and
pull in my own way you better pull your
own weight aggression with other ladies
play with this I have no problem
your attic sheeted chicken and nests
looking at the post carnage report and
looking at the kills of you away oh you
want me to play flakes lady is it the
same mystery for you too is it the same
thing can you could you play with your
significant other very in competitive
games or is off-limits off-limits
he doesn't play at all like Oh mm-hmm
he'll watch me play um he encouraged me
to play that's the way he doesn't play
is he supporting what you you what you
do be on my level so he doesn't bring me
down like a problem on the men's side
because I've had multiple chicks of my
life that has had serious issues with be
playing games you go because it's like
at least he's not out in the club like
some people man and women are so
self-centered they don't want they don't
any attention going to anything it's a
human being or a machine not them dizzy
is on you he said na addict that's the
females you get with but dizzy we can't
act like you ain't heard stuff before
ladies save question could you play
competitively with your significant
other women my criteria
you got to play video games how good you
play but I can be I can be competitive
that's the point that I don't want to
like go to sleep but if your game I feel
like your significant others should
either be like a setting of your hobby
of your passion or gaming and enjoy
you like broken here it smell like smart
you have more money to go out later on
opposed to you you know take you to go
this week but if you had game pass you
will have money to go out the king
before game pass and the king after game
paths are two entirely different
relations we got all day we got some
topic suit the BG for being petty about
as the ladies around the question that
we asked all the guests that I'll become
start you first because you've been here
before but I need to know
your list has revised the Sims in
general yes let's go
hallo super 8mm ocarina of time
educating black black a game like so
many times and last but new to my list
oriented life force to me that games
perfect sound music gameplay it just the
feel of it is fantastic if you played
Walsall games and if you're a
Metroidvania fan my worry is checks all
the boxes so you can't wait for the new
one can't wait I know that's what's up
so we got that five in that's a five
okay Super Mario World
mm-hmm Metal Gear Solid Red Dead
Redemption we're not going glance over
these these classics right here that's
only one of the best fallout in made by
super mario world classic like the first
Mario game that really took me read
never just YouTube I bust a bust out to
talk about it good game and I've always
been a Call of Duty fan black ops 2 what
the like the massive explosion of what
Call of Duty is and I mastered prestiged
I got to I played all the zombie maps
and that's like I love it strong that's
just a trilogy
[Laughter]
she's went back and looked at every
Yahoo didn't say what series of my
favorite is black bag and origins those
are like yeah or just got to be that guy
man I prefer the oldest s is great over
the new way god bless I want honestly
halo consoles got me stuck in this hole
[Music]
please hang on how the dawn again two
dollars thank you lord
PS throw attic in the bush talk about
Skyward Sword I got you so now you just
gotta like a game and you gotta keep
sword man baby in and the people have
spoken to the question with the Nintendo
switch having surpassed are coming close
to passing the Xbox one and console
sales do you think the switch will
continue its momentum once the series X
and PS five arrives the winner of a
razor close three-way ILP poll with 43%
of the vote was the there is no stopping
the switch train group will good to you
it's only with exclusives coming in that
second place right on the heels 42
percent was the without switch Pro
switch will slow down and be less
relevant with next gen arrives and in
last place with only 40 percent of the
vote was I don't care gay pass and
remote play gonna come to the switch
anyway
[Laughter]
stick with domina Spencer well
especially when you buying from the
house I mean if we're providing you
services I think you need to sit down
and relax relax okay you definitely put
yourself in the bushes
yes you definitely know the view was
Google and Amazon these are the White
Walkers and these are what you're
supposed to be afraid of no we all know
that dance moves Ryan has capitulated
and you know devastate he's in pocket
and Reggie Fiza may said I'm not with
that with the switches brother get down
cuz Bowser he look like he in pocket -
so what
point-in-time all you're gonna
understand the real people that cannot
be purchase they cannot be bought all
right they cannot be kicked away Google
is trying to figure out stadia get him
Ollie we kill a beast while he wounded
because let me tell you something that
stadia with a hit from the beginning you
already been a problem alright because
they already first to the market so Phil
knows well and you know I keep saying
Phil but it's the whole Microsoft
division but Phil is their head so we're
not talking about Cesar we don't talk
about Cesar all right so Cesar
understands that we must keep them down
so this you have is a three prong
approach you're gonna have hardware
you're gonna have software and you're
gonna have services right that's the
only way that they can compete with
these bigger pocket guys you know Google
has a hell of a lot of money Amazon has
a hell of a lot of money and Amazon has
been in gaming if you didn't know they
have been in gaming in the background my
question to the realm is is Phil right
for saying that the bigger problem is
Google and Amazon opposed to saying
Nintendo and Sony right well let's frame
it before I give it give it to lazy bro
he basically came out he said look he
had a ton of respect for them but he
said he definitely you know he sees
Amazon and Google as his main
competitors moving forward he said he's
not trying to be disrespectful to
Nintendo Sega
I mean Sony but traditional game
companies are somewhat out of position
he said I guess to your point they could
recreate Asia but they've invested it
meaning Microsoft you know tons of
millions billions of dollars in cloud
over the years and the last point he
made I believe was in reference to he
said I don't want to be in a fight over
format Wars with these guys while Amazon
and Google are focusing on how to get
gaming to seven billion people around
the world ultimately that's his goal so
let's bring it to lays around you know a
lot of people are upset in the social
sphere by fales comments do you agree or
do you disagree
anyone could jump from lady'd lie anyone
could jump in I will agree because how
technology is built for the future it's
gonna be more seamless than ever
yes hardware will be a focus but not the
main focus
especially with our data in our Wi-Fi
capabilities and with the depending on
where we live it will expose us to more
and more games Phil is thinking about
the big picture he's thinking about the
long haul as far as gaming his concern
and yes if I was Phil I will be looking
at Amazon and Google because they got
the pockets and he truly believes that
he he he's not worried about like the
Xbox atmosphere because I I think he
knows how loyal Xbox fans are but he
wants more people to know how great of a
product it is and ain't nothing wrong
with that I don't and look if the Tendo
and people feel disrespected between the
Tendo and Sony then they just gotta go
to back to the drawing room and
formulate a plan so they can catch up
not with just Xbox but with Amazon and
Google as well and they're not gonna do
that it didn't sound young part of game
you can easily die real real quick so
it's either adapt or you know Phil's job
as head of Xbox is to think long term
vision sometimes we as gamers we focus
too much on the here and now when he
starts talking like that work and you
know thinking about big picture and
things like that he's thinking about the
overall long-term vision because just
look at it like that this not doesn't
mean that the companies I focus on
short-term it's just that he has also
think about let me let me let me push
back on all y'all for a second what
about you know don't you say y'all
getting consoles this how do y'all talk
about they the competition yeah I need
to worry about the MVP and winning these
sales they're making money for them hmm
that's all that matters as long as
they're able to pay their shareholders
not your honor
making money there ain't much to put
money into the platform that's all that
matters like I don't get this like y'all
arguing about nothing Nathan and for my
last little bit it's called a marathon
not a sprint
I just wanted people again back to
whatever you were saying like oh one
nobody says anything about like
restaurants you are number one and
they're still in business like just
because you're not number one number one
does not mean you can't operate good
point
like you don't have to be null again
like a bug in a lot of said what was
your business plan is sound you are
still able to pay your overhead cost and
permit in your pocket you are still
coming on it you just go still work at
it and work your craft and do what
you're supposed to do and exactly where
Xbox is doing no doubt shoutout to
gaming for time mystery brother fire on
a super chair glad to have this podcast
in the community your dedication to the
craft the industry leaders you showcase
is amazing hashtag proud to be a game
Wow salute brother Forte means a lot oh
yeah we missed the of Raven yeah alright
see you guys get B's training services
the memorandum is Sony is with trading
semiconductors for AI and with Microsoft
Azure Google is easier than Sony and
Nikki oh we got 66 69 G yes because they
have the money and the resources listed
all of easi said we've got a $2.00 super
chart from BG I can't lose so company
you're not competing with it was like um
what Sony decided to use as your servers
it's like it's like they on the same
team that
[Laughter]
Phil Phil out-of-pocket for saying this
I think people I think people let this
console war stuff get too much like at
the end of the day you know is he saying
that Playstations not a competitor no he
never said that he just said to a point
the only competitors he sees as a liable
threat in their overall business is your
wallet like mine is the cloud computing
you know that's what their obviously
everything they've been building up to
now is leading to this cloud
infrastructure they're not building this
for two year
for now the building this for five to
seven years from now they may hidden at
the end of the day it's not necessarily
huge uh you know a lot of the times it
just goes to who does something better
but as you can see when it comes to
Netflix you know who it's you know
Google Plus might be a better service in
certain areas but Netflix got there
first so that's that's their goal they
want to be there from the ground floor
and they want to get that initial we we
were here first we have this brand here
already no don't listen when you take a
hard l I've been saying oh what do you
do change the conversation so he changed
the conversation why doing a very good
job excellent conversation because the
fact of the matter is I love Xbox the
fact of the matter is head-to-head with
Sony quantifying things the way they've
been quantified to this day which is
console sales
you know triple-a first party stuff if
you continue to quantify things in that
way they're always gonna take the L
they're gonna take the Eldar to the to
Nintendo they're gonna take the other
place things yeah we gotta be careful
though because I believe Charisse made a
good point when we say our we gotta be
careful as far as saying not number one
but still profitable
oh no absolutely it has always been the
case right that's always been the
fanboys argument right the fanboy
argument we've always said it why is
Microsoft still here they get destroyed
so badly right they're still making
money right it's still making money he
changed that conversation right so that
the fact of the matter is that Microsoft
as a whole is looking to the future and
if you think about cloud services right
it's very forward facing in the gaming
space for us because that's what we care
about right right and we have a
figurehead those fences that figurehead
for that as a whole Microsoft is looking
to cloud for a number of different
applications right and then so if you
think about the article where Phil said
this specifically that is not a gaming
publication this is
business publication right so he's
talking about my so you said that he
wasn't talking to no gay magazine so
that's we're not competition if you look
if you look at the article right the
article explains how gaming got to here
right you don't you don't go through
that whole spiel in an article if you're
talking to people who already know the
conversation right so it has to like
introduce the subject matter to the
people reading this are you saying is I
just wanna be clear this is the
financial publication and you know they
did have the gaming Sony and it knows
not really as I always do it the
overarching narrative in gaming right
now was not moving towards this cloud
future right it's been around forever
and for a long time it was a laughing
stock it was it was vapor where this is
now real if they if they don't have that
Avenue to pivot to right then there's no
way to pivot to then you still have to
you have to still be in the conversation
about head to head with Sony and with
Nintendo and they they would be in it
there would be a problem there because
like I said in no world do they win that
argument they just don't that's not
they've never won that argument
yeah the closest I've ever come to
winning that argument it's a 360 and
then you know I want a shout out to the
one I just so many not immediately he
said we are lies broke poor fools they
don't have any money or business sense
and we'll never have any money to stop
trying to tell a trillion dollar company
how to make money shaking my head pocket
watching fools
yeah I get to find out from the Raven
flow dudes a kind of funny new film
through a passive-aggressive shade as
one says though is changing the subject
while keeping his side I need to go
change talking about a conversation
where you're just getting the story no
changing that whole collar super chat
case in point ladies are more
intelligent these queen eavesdropping
educated calculated facts ponies just
goes dive into them advice get messy
lMNO with the $10 a woodshed bill saying
sony was never in the business of
servers and cloud for corporations it
takes billions Sony will need to
piggyback and pay up and who's got a
super super poetic boxing politics
please thank you no man that's s it
honestly
again I think looking forward that is
that's the move they're gonna make
absolutely and it and they're poised
looking at all the other services out
there and the way once again they're
providing it as an option they are ones
that are best poised to take off
completely so you're wrong everybody
agree kind of said I agree with this is
the long-term play this is the long-term
play that's just the reality of it you
know this is you know whether it be five
ten years down the road you know
definitely streaming on some level is
what they're trying to do and I know a
lot of people like hey it hasn't really
worked successfully yet or look at what
stadia or whatever you know they kind of
bungled out the gate by the end of the
day the service itself does work you
know I mean so it just comes down to the
implementation you know how they go
about doing that getting into more
regions
obviously we know about you know the
game past ultimate most likely will
integrate X cloud and that kind of stuff
and then you know kind of getting as far
as as your server as far as their their
footprint you know I'm saying kind of
take now I will say this you know as far
as
stadia I'm we know what has happened you
know say there's glorified beta you know
and people look at that
so you see it doesn't work but I will
say this people better not sleep on
Amazon only for the simple fact that you
know AWS is pretty strong out there you
know I'm saying as far as in the
business tent on the cloud level you
know they're very strong out there and
then also you know as far as down
obviously this is a big if if they show
the commitment to gaming right you still
have a possibility of them with the
infrastructure with twitch integration
and I'm saying we know Amazon Prime is
out there you know they could be a
serious threat and the rumors are they
are coming with something whether it be
in 2020 soon they are coming with
something so again how you know that's
implemented there's gonna be interested
but to me the biggest issue
Microsoft has to worry about and I want
to shout out Matt piscatella from MPD I
want to show before is this is the big
thing we know Microsoft and Phil he was
that 7 billion like he said right he was
that that mobile market that the people
who would never traditionally buy
consoles or those regions where consoles
don't do well right but the thing is
he's got to understand and this is why I
hope I got to see how to handle it let's
be real you know do I like a lot of
mobile gamers come from the free 99
school mobile gamers don't like paying
for services and stuff like that so
they've got to figure out a way to
attract that crowd is that options
already available is know what stopped
you from buying anything that's the part
people they just think services I gotta
pay per month you don't you don't have
to
I think the choose to do that you could
choose the option I think they just got
a I think they have to figure out a way
to incentivize I like what they're doing
with the ISPs when you look at the SK
Telecom deal Korea and stuff like that
highly implementing X cloud with the ISP
deals I think in the u.s. is t-mobile
you know I'm saying I like that I like
that but you gotta figure out a way to
get those mobile guys who just maybe
they'll just jump on a I'll do that
candy crush or whatever it is you know
saying and then they bouncing you know
say like they gotta figure out a way to
make X cloud kind of sexy to those
people that there they are putting out
games that are on mobile unit
to like get people familiar with the
Xbox brand because I play a Gears pop
religiously like if every time you see
me I'm wherever I'm at I'm playing my
gears popping you know do my little
gears pop thing and what I've noticed is
when they first showed it at e3 yeah but
I don't hear anybody talking that crap
about it at all like now that is in
awhile is actually something that you
can actually put in is really really fun
what what they need to do is strategize
that aspect of it have little developers
that are doing that so you get used to
the Xbox brand and then they can you
know have an attack on the mobile market
in that form give that free money man I
swear to God I wasn't gonna buy is free
I'm having fun but what bad thing is how
do they leverage ex-con you know they
want X cloud in everybody you know like
downloadable app give them the 30 day
free are you gonna have to do something
to let them touch to get them in a day
well you know what I think is going to
be a separate service in certain regions
that it'll be free now if you have your
games you can play your games through
the X cloud right but if if you want to
get down for the get-down then you know
you go and get the game pass get the
game pass ultimate and then your parlor
that super eco system where you get
these free games every month and you're
like that's when you start to see the
benefit I think there's gonna be that's
where the argument gets a little touchy
and difficult because a lot of those
people may not care about the core games
right right how do you how do you
convince them to pay 15 dollars or
whatever it is for three quarters of a
service they don't want they have to
figure that out that's why he gets paid
those big bucks and he's trying to get
that aurelius name is just that look at
the end of day between all three though
I still feel as sure they're a nice
cloud is the way to go because the
studio acquisitions to me is that that
to me is showcasing that okay we are
going to have content on our service the
biggest
steak Stadium is obviously glorified
beta and then you got to pay again for
these full price games then they got
older games the library's very little
and then who knows what Amazon is doing
on that we have to say that from a
studio and a services perspective Azure
and s cloud is by far ahead like it's
not even close on that level Sol $4.99
thank you so much sir
don't you mean two billion gamers there
are seven billion gamers there's seven
seven billion to a billion pushing on
earth and is still too much poverty did
Phil say that understand what you're
saying
Phil actually actually says and I quote
he said I don't want to be in a fight
over format Wars while these guys while
Amazon with these other guys meaning
Nintendo listening while Amazon and
Google are focusing on how to get gaming
to seven billion people around the world
right so let's get death singer got that
I got wait worried that's yeah he was
above that we missed them okay oh then
we have one won't get Jay T against Ola
nothing with the five-pound super chat
let's keep it real Xbox is the best
boxes for the corner no pre to the truth
they are not competition The Last of Us
is overrated wow that's a little extra
but I'll be playing The Last of Us
people are trained to respond and
purchase things and Microsoft has been
on the forefront of all these things we
ever said didn't want digital look at us
now all digital now Microsoft's all
services no doubt no doubt this is true
everybody just got a new one I so we got
the one bad mother-- dangerous are
gamers many mobile gamers have multiple
subscriptions they not had the option
for high quality gaming where gaming
where our gaming started so he's pretty
much saying that it's not necessarily
that mobile gamers won't pay for
something they just haven't had the
quality of games to pay for some shall
see yeah that's gotta be the thing it
will will Ex cloud the service those
level of triple-a experiences be enough
to attract you know
Moonves keep doing the waiting doing
with these games I'm looking at the list
right now I'm looking at the games that
they're just recently added to it and
people say well there's a lot of games
leaving not as much as they're adding to
it you know that you may lose for but
you get like six to ten Yoshi mark Louis
he said I'm on my petty twelve teraflops
greater than nine or garden look we
gotta move on to the next time before we
move I just gotta ask the lazing around
no we go along LRU okay let me know if
anybody's got the roll or anything
please let us know yeah make sure
everyone in honesty missed him um they
need to make the gear series similar to
GTA and FF Final Fantasy making each
iteration like a new IP like Final
Fantasy great show salute to the ladies
no I don't I don't know like if you made
that that would be weird because like
gears has already established a story of
universe like Final Fantasy doesn't have
a dedicated story or dedicated moves
everything's always new perfect segue
Furguson man made the announcement you
know that um he would joining blizzard
to oversee the Diablo franchise so you
know Frank Ferguson he's been around for
a while
responsible for so many things so many
projects getting done on our time I
believe BioShock Infinite um Unreal
Tournament Lost Planet and obviously the
Gears of War franchise so this is a huge
lost by the coalition and he's going
over to Blizzard who seems to be in the
business of taking people
Microsoft we don't not good Fred to the
rel Mike Ibarra is there and yes I want
to bring us to mom you know our C Multi
multi attack on this in the fence of one
you know what do we think about this
news you know to obviously the future
you know of coalition will forward any
gears franchise and stuff like that and
then on yeah then obviously blizzard so
let's get this actually started the
North first we'll get it back over to
Lane I want to start off with um so I
get a chance to talk to you about this
I'm very curious where you are with this
whole Ferguson thing um I mean first
shout-out to him like ID to go over see
obviously Diablos a big deal and he's
the type of guy I think they need
somebody in charge over there obviously
technically sound and knows and loves
and love the franchise so I think it you
know they need a new face over there to
sort of Shepherd that and get a little
Blizzard at this point they need all the
hell did yeah does anyone know any
experience in that genre luck at all
what's wrong with Diablo yeah had very
different games I mean I don't know
specifically that just like I don't know
his background like that but like I feel
like gears is such like a diverse game
from what he's been working on like I
don't
it's kind of weird that he like he
didn't go there is just like like a
regular dude like he's running in here's
the thing Tom what is it's a point that
I didn't miss one of his qualities is
that he is no forgetting things out
writing them complete getting them done
right so we've all heard the stories
about the Diablo development and what's
going on right so if the thought process
is if they bringing him on like they
want this thing to kind of ship out like
it needs to come out kind of thing so
I'll be that's what the industry say but
continue solving an addict illogical and
I think and I think they absolutely need
that you know every talk about Blizzard
Time Rush to become to develop this game
and so you know you have to get game
down the timely fashion because you want
to the more time you spend making a game
the more money you spend on making the
game they need to get so I think he
perfect person for that and I've the
fact that maybe he doesn't have a lot of
experience particularly in that genre I
like it well um so that goes that goes
to how what I think about him leaving
and how that leaves coalition but it was
just with you with just wanting the same
stuff over and over but if you don't
like I want to see gears do something
different it's different when you give
me gears tactus and it's a different
genre altogether like Sears fan
watch me help me let me let me hear so
what's yourself like why did I don't
know I get tired of the the hiding
behind cover popping out okay let me ask
you this so let's get to the crux of
this because this isn't it's but
question to you that is do you want like
a change in the vein like how what kid
doesn't like which is where god of war
kind of reinvented it's all reinvented
desire itself you want a complete
abandonment of the cover-to-cover style
I say abandon me yo take a risk one time
I want him to explain to me what kind of
you know driving skin convinced the
gears would have to change up the entire
core of its foundation we cannot compare
the what church' gears it was a single
parent a toothpaste and one day when he
talked about what they did this in the
game initially initially they talked
about it like the changes were well more
wide sweeping so your mouth little face
with us it was what they call it was it
was you know you know how you have like
a game that's kind of wide but it's
still direct
something real quick at the end of the
day they have gear coalition making
gears they have halo three four three
making halo they're like look we need
more diversity we need more types of
games for other people to play they
don't like the cover of shoes I don't
like the first-person shooter that's why
they bought that's why they bought
undead labs that's why they bought made
a new studio tuition that's why they
don't meet you have to change
I love dears I just wanted to take some
risks Nobita have you plated just the
ending decision alone is different than
everything I know we gave them a maze
but but question destroy us quit run
we're gonna get that calm down what I
was gonna say I gotta ask this what risk
would be except the woody you give me an
example something that gears could you
where you say okay now this is something
different this is the cover just one
yo here's three cool risk mistake I see
girls 5 is a huge risk when you compare
gears for two gears five very different
let's go oh he said we studio will
always be about gears I think with him
going cold ranch out with new I then we
got sovereign Cognito right on King I
wanted that Aphrodite Aphrodite chamber
order
Jonathan be solved the type of person to
be like this rising in for you can't be
guarded by do like ticket I dove is just
more halos gears of Forza that narrative
is only allowed by Xbox fans every
single Zelda kind of reinvents itself
right every single doesn't know the
difference I've ever seen was breaking
plane every
was exactly the same way way core of
Zelda is the same every game we're sure
the first person he wants the first
person Zelda that's the cover Zelda
fight fight fight Dukes are up raven
flow fire on a suture if you don't want
cliffie be call stop and pop gameplay to
something else is right oh my god me and
Frankie in single-player damn you read
it is like this
we gotta move off from that but we could
continue or this insurance you have you
expensive or lady your special support I
need to know you know as far as this
whole you know raw leaving like it's
gears in trouble you know where do you
think about the impact mover for it now
lady or should we take oh I think the
outlaws in trouble mmm I don't I think
he said up team high if I'm sure people
at his studio knew that he had applied
for this deal I went to the process
interview I'm sure there are no secrets
in this industry I'm sure they knew and
I'm sure he had people in place to take
over if he actually got the job so the
fact that they are looking for somebody
of his caliber mm-hmm I think Diablo is
the one that's in trouble I feel like
nothing he gets wrong but he's been
working on a third-person cover shooter
for 15 years Diablo but you still don't
know the ins and out of that like you
know it's like I said I don't know
everything with Robert secret bit over
there sneak in some some visits for the
past year and a half yeah what I feel
like you know it's easier to promote
someone from within on gears to make
that stay on track than it is to breed
someone that's light a studio that
hasn't even made anything close to
Diablo 450 well he ain't been there for
15 years I'm like in a leadership but
you get what I'm saying downloads that
much in trouble that what they've shown
us so far is gonna get restarted with
the open the thing I agree completely
with Cherise off is that again look at
rods track Ricky what he's known for
getting projects completed and that's an
activation Bethesda and Blizzard love so
to move but you know at the end of the
day having new blood like Rob Ferguson
there could
shakin could could be what they need
shooter here's a question that obviously
since this had this announcement went
down you know I would see that the names
went out and there's two questions I got
asked one you know obviously you know
Mike Ibarra has gone over there so
accusing him of poaching Rob Ferguson
and in the second part was obviously
about you know one of the og Sweden
Games franchise which is cliffy B he had
made a tweet out and it was like is it
time to give cliffy B a call or is that
relationship for based on his lack of
successes I don't think it's I think
it's laying his law breakers call today
cliff he doesn't want to return as like
a full-blown employee wants the cons he
wants to talk to them about
I think he's washed out yeah it's funny
because like cliffy B would be the one
that I but I come back in and blow
everything out right and start fresh
right but I kind of agree like cliffie
cliffie Zinn his own head man like I
don't know he's not here's the that I
don't riggers and like and the other
what was the other one on overheated a
light daddy one with the N I was a bad
we tried to get the battle royal
I don't know what about song I got there
but this he he got the original
blueprints and he said he got ideas that
was King Olaf that was left with a cut
listen any time you do something and it
tick off from where was that um he's
talking all this mess when you bring
your spicy you supposed to come out
there you know pounding your chest you
know cliff he definitely did great
things for the industry okay so what he
made my said everybody has the flops and
stuff like that but to say that he
wouldn't be wanted I believe I would
want them I don't want your ideas what
about do you think it's possible he may
have burned too many bridges on the way
I think so I think so but you know
humble pie makes a great men of us all
you know you you you walk back you as
you walking back in the door you have to
look those people in the eye that you
kicked in the butt when he was walking
out you know I'm sorry I apologize
kamesh of a man give the man a chance to
say he's sorry and let him come back I
know he burned us Xbox dude over there
with their PlayStation face and how good
your sauce was over there and they don't
like your sauce so you know you got a
little humble pie and I would love for
you to come back and just sit down and
relax
let's get your ideas out let's fresh on
let's get you back to prominence man I
don't like his knees like that what you
think about cliff I'm here I'm not
hearing positive responses from y'all
I'm not gonna be like chicken
dudes new jobs to see what games come
out until I see games that come out
every this is the problem with people
right there more focus on what who goes
somewhere else to work on what project
instead of the actual projects that
coming out and if it brought water we've
years he has a right to be and and us as
consumers we just go have to if you have
to gears
I know it's heartbreaking for you but
that may have been on that for 15 years
don't you think maybe he's just tired of
working on here maybe maybe he wants to
work on something else and same with
mine maybe he just he been on Xbox for a
minute now you want to do something else
but they say lady they serve bike out
here poached it's how NATO homeboy here
who come up because I was mine and I
knew there was a job money only series
let's go it's not poaching it's like
either you either if another company
comes up to you with the proposition and
portfolio about what they want to give
you as a salary either the other
companies are gonna match it or they
gonna let it go that's what we Blizzard
so B if it becomes a success that's good
if it's not oh well but that's his
choice that same energy that I give
these PlayStation dudes when they head
to companies and everything leave
alright so I know you guys know said
then be like Oh King fraud and he came
out here you know Ferguson love let me
tell you something is different when you
leave in a cover of night with no no
letter no note no nothing just wake up
your boy is going this Kohl's is doing
everything this is parent your man is
going over to another company you know
exactly where he is and how he's going
is nothing to hide
see what my problem is these Sony dudes
leaving like poof to the ether so he
actually took the job and I understand I
feel like it's poaching then I mean you
ain't never been a position that you got
a job offer in and you had another job
to match or he's good at his job
what why not why not I mean I really
can't speak I was I had
[Music]
these decisions aren't made lightly at
all when it comes to somebody that was
in his position as being a head of a
studio so I'm pretty sure that there's a
plan in place for placement so on and so
forth but this is this is business know
I need to get her take on cliffie is is
that a good move to bring him back or
not fair you had your time we good on
you like where you habitat where I'm at
with cliffy I just feel like the last
she had like he put out two games was it
uncle heights I think it was and then
the law breakers and so we kind of like
soft clothes I'm not saying that the
dude can't come by if they feel like
they need him he wants some fresh eyes I
mean I feel like this is last year's e3
week where I asked them what can change
on it none of the
ninja they should build off the tactics
as the new XCOM that's cool
now here's the big get I gotta bring
somebody get that click is it the final
super super victor okay
cliff he needs a second chance his games
were ripoffs but they were solid for
double a's raagh pushed the chair on
push for changing black tests into
coalition which I don't think that's
accurate I think Microsoft is I don't
know yeah I don't know anything back
there but he wasn't tired look man the
may worked on gears for 15 years if he
wants to go do something else
15 years making one game I didn't I
didn't even do it for 15 years and I'm
tired for head now he's a guy guy I try
to sell this again to delay
he said cliffy B said the offer still
stands to console Hillary said the worst
thing was players like this this is the
belly nice bunch she said abuzz
something about mr. Lee Perry who I
believe was an epic designer he said
they have unused ideas
in the back door if you look at it from
a standpoint of who he is as a person
because we all know he's a very cocky
individual and do you really think that
him being as a consulate is going to
work because he's gonna want to push his
ideas and if they say no he's gonna act
early two-thousands like dude bro
cockiness that's not gonna fly in his
day at the door he said the offer still
on the table so clearly they don't know
you know a big enough outcry to bring
cliffie back I think I got a shot
what you need to do cliff because I
understand I felt I felt the pain you
got the bag you know and you had to show
loyalty to somebody that wasn't gonna
show loyalty to you you didn't know they
was gonna do you how to ditch but I knew
they was gonna do you how they did you
see but the house is already available
for you to come back in you know I'm not
a mom I'm not sharing the same opinions
of a lot of people here that you did huh
but we could make that video and you
need to bend the knee and beg for Xbox
forgiveness and I believe we got a river
flow to our chat I love cliff but he's a
pretty pretty princess it's true and
booty need to ask a borrow if he'd like
to
in addition we do not agree with slo-mo
just watch them have enemies in Diablo
that looks just like a locust one way
dragon with the - no I just don't care
like I feel like gears is gonna be on
track you know me
III am a little worried since we're all
Ferguson's gone but at the same time you
know I do feel like they'll promote from
within I have no clue who they'll do it
I don't think it's gonna divert too much
on the tracks I don't know what to see
when gear 6 comes out even if they make
a gear 6 they could be doing a new IP
who knows but at the same time like this
man says what out on Twitter and he's
been extra that he he is almost on the
same level as I do from PlatinumGames
that blocks people who see keep speaking
English alright so you can't go out and
be this extra all the time and then be
going you know Microsoft uh you know we
know Rob Ferguson just left and I know
that you're a little bit worried about
though I'm here return to Z the fact
that he got the Twitter speaks volumes
that does kind of speak volumes that he
can't get in contact most likely really
we got we got we got a grandpa can you
go super late I'm sorry we want to make
this the last one which is the yeah you
know people leaving
so this past week Dan houses one of the
two co-founders of rockstar games
um vacated by take-two that he didn't
make a roster the sudden even pull out a
statement it was take two to put out a
statement to the investor indicating
that dan Houser would be permanently
leaving in March so beta dan Houser was
the one that was most responsible for
the narrative and the story and an
overall sort of like direction of where
GTA has gone and where Red Dead is going
what do you guys think about this you
think it changes the way Rockstar
dusting do you take a change it affects
how narrative is sort of handled in an
GTA games and Red Dead games moving
forward do you think it better keep be
business as usual I'm a jump on this
first I say I don't care about Rockstar
Phil get on the phone on their house out
here you gotta get into games you gotta
do what you gotta do part of me feels
like she's retired Department feels like
he can definitely be a lead writer of GA
and Red Dead is out here loose throw
back the truck up give him a boy smokey
right now remember they still in the
position to purchase studios and put you
know studios in places so let's not act
like you know they're not you know
working with dollars to UM feel like
they spent their whole rent money on
sunset overdrive it's probably so but I
feel him leaving Rockstar really doesn't
change anything at all
um I think they're gonna continue
business as usual
the man is filthy rich apparently he was
a big person he's one of the biggest
reasons that it was his team that was
wearing them I was going to Riley so
well sure when it gets busy hands off so
you want to have him he was working he
was we all know there's crunch stone or
Microsoft
invented to crunch you're highly
successful sir
but maybe you crunch the gamer he was
the head writer Thank You Fonzarelli
everything so all we think I want to
know now everything goes through the
house of brothers like ant that final
word on anything gameplay um story it
goes with the house right now people
don't leave these positions for no
reason as we can see with Rod Fergusson
the only thing I want to know
was a great game it was worth $60 Reds
good I'm sorry I you know just because
of red don't have to buy some right red
dead right this is the thing I think the
damage has been done one side of me
tells me like rock stars distant machine
things it's gonna be business as usual
right but without him there and without
that thing with everything they have is
that rock star goes through both Houser
brothers they'll be a different business
the creative brother left it seems like
a really bad team a movie like one
brother goes to another company they had
a rock star movie with a Harry Potter
has my house
I feel like everyone over there over
there a tray of a rockstar they're all
corrupted because they made Red Dead
just throw them all in the bushes you
don't tell me if I got no tape I ain't
got no tape what if that red did in the
new grand theft comes out you can't come
out GTA 6 would be worse than GTA 5 but
it take to stock have smothered
officially since he has left already
down the 6o in a single day since the
Bravo
yeah we thought we hello down we got
money to buy used to take to start menu
but I want to bind that before it goes
back up when they drop that rock stars I
need to do what you feel early so dude
as far as I'm Dan I mean they say he's
been gone for a while since spring last
year so it's something that they've
pretty much already got you see him not
being around not being there and that's
party that was probably part of the
reason as to why he did it this way you
know was since I think say I think the
color this is I think this is not really
gonna fake the game too much of whatever
other games are there they're working on
as far as where he goes no I don't know
would you would you be is it what do you
think I don't know he's got that right
look at the financials I'm gonna call it
too big of a stench
if it wasn't it would be a new thing
like let's say just how they gave
Darrell Gallagher if they wants to do
something like that with with dad house
I don't know anything but but I'm not
this extra for no reasons the game
honestly it doesn't bother me on it
because I see everybody loves you tastes
like it so I don't have this this
history with this series and everybody
loves my first red date was rated - it
was nice I enjoyed it I don't see why
people think it's a bad game but we
don't comment on it so take a vacation
and not deal with this crap anymore
I don't know do you boo it's not your
bag the highest bag you can I am NOT
gonna hate on that you want to cut the
Microsoft comes right on just you know
mm-hmm that's nice wait that's what game
every six years every day I guess so no
don't fill slide the deal
the day you know read that might not
have been the biggest game to me but you
know it did appeal to a huge amount of
people like everyone in the chat is
saying addict addict daddy got a guy I
read it and you know if you told her
that many people give me another day
make another horse simulator I don't
care the same thing but they only going
at you but he's really walking there
with the blank that can be like alright
and I'll tell you if it's fine if it's
doable anyway we gotta get this is a
funny show good show we will skip the
last Jack get right to the pole enroll
new ILP poll with the recent statements
by Phil Spencer that Xbox views Amazon
and Google as their main competitors
going forward do you think this is a
mistake
by Microsoft to not include Sony and
Nintendo as direct competitors yes
Xbox is being dominated by Saudi
Nintendo in the console space they need
to focus on exclusives first be no cloud
infrastructure is the long term play for
the future
Phil is ahead of the curve or see I
don't care until stadia and Amazon
actually get some games
please rock that with neck goes slightly
Monday or Tuesday the ladies of grown
women gaming in a building
IOP collabo lips what's up this is the
first clapper we've had a long podcast
yeah we can define people find let's
start with Lady infamous we're gonna
find people find what you got going on
um I want to thank everyone in the chat
for coming through and showing us love
growing a game in audience with y'all I
see y'all coming through much love thank
you guys for everyone in the panel or
inviting us and thank you for my lovely
pair of grown women in the building you
already know you can check me out on
Twitch lady underscore infamous four one
five and you can check me on Twitter
lady underscore infamous xxx thank you
so much for your hospitality appreciate
it
lady in the building finally in the
round
thank you for the invite I do appreciate
it thanks for one chef rockin out with a
very late we appreciate the love came in
Saturday's noon eastern nine Pacific
we're there every Saturday usually
except for this week obviously because
of the iron Laurence but yeah thank you
and you got something to catch me on
Twitter Delilah on ass crazy and I'll be
around
and of course ladies you keep it it's
spicy today what is going on wicked a
popular fad you first of all I can't
thank y'all for having us your chat has
been awesome y'all have been awesome Oh
like I follow y'all on Twitter but it
was a lot of fun
absolutely love we definitely gotta do
it again without - salut of course
l-boogie
regular of the realm regular roundtable
with the stream boy Lord PhD Rock
Mondays and Tuesdays that is family
right solutely I know she can go to the
whole show but she stayed in we were
rockin and again absolute pleasure
salute lazer run please support them
every Saturday you heard it's 12 p.m.
Eastern what I'm saying please rock the
baby out here they moving and shaking
grown women opinions they really play
these games
no frighten they really out here so
please support them the ladies around
we'd like to see you continue to grow to
see what you're doing so that it was
substituted on that Lord addict out here
spicy with the redneck talks or type of
drama today you can find the item on
Twitter at Lord addict LP you can find
me on I don't even know the numbers on
Xbox these days I'm Lord addict
something it's like a four before other
dishes you knows me crazy I've never
seen you have although some dude that
got on Xbox Live six years ago never
logged on again took Lauren addicts I
gotta get the numbers you know you know
what I wanna shout outs to the chat you
guys been extremely supportive today hit
that like button you guys love mine you
don't go put there I'm gonna put our
guests Twitter in the UH in the chat
definitely go follow them you know they
absolutely I'm calling them the calendar
versions of the Lord's I put the YouTube
up in there
shut the Philly Eagle he was like y'all
supporting them right now subscribing
right now so we got that happiness
return for switch talk but I don't think
they were happy for your gears talk Opie
and bx sovereign on PSN Xbox Live Big
Shot really are fantastic absolutely
fantastic that like addicts said guys go
out there and follow them we got the
opportunity to meet these ladies last
year parties you know
yes we are
we hope you we gotta take the pic and
all that I hope it's gonna be late yes
absolutely fantastic great to have you
on the show
what else one more thing oh yeah try to
find out the information to get
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
exclusive you have to ask what I didn't
like I didn't like a couple of things I
think a video should have been done to
show that you know people actually do
get together and they actually are on
one accord because it's something
special to behold to see all the people
that you know that are influencers of
all Jo all colors is not that let's keep
it real everybody's up there doing one
thing their passion and their passion
has no color so you know we we we
definitely have a great time it gets a
little cold the blankets come out um and
that's when
[Music]
yes yes yes so go check that out
um you know the Green Goblin should get
as much love as its Joker and um trust
me he is worse than the Joker he killed
one Stacy very early on um I'm gonna
give a shout-out to a grown woman gaming
oh these women actually really game is
no joke no hyperbole when I'm telling
you this stuff guys
Oh little-known fact the video that went
viral of me playing X cloud
Delilah was she's there she's in them
she's in the mix oh listen listen he
said these are real gamers not just
women gamers they're gamers all right so
just take that women name out of it and
they're gamers all right so let's get
that stigma out of here um it was a
great show I was so happy when I knew
you guys was coming on because I like me
to be shined on you guys all right go
we'll go sign up go follow them on
Twitter and make sure that you watch at
least two shows so you can get a feel
exactly what's going on you'll be hooked
support the realm you already knowing
like I said I was cut they were kind
enough to have me on the show it's like
like they're out here I keep telling you
there's a lot of gamers that are not
outside they're not at the events
they're not the shows you know me and
they're out and it's always a pleasure
running into them every year
you know the rooftop analogy shake you
know I'm saying it's always cool to see
you know again really happy to have you
guys in the room this was a ton of fun
please make sure you support it
subscribe to channel it's - a couple
episodes and see what they talk about
they're definitely for real for real
I don't everybody look enjoy your sunny
please support Lords of gaming Garnett
we really appreciate that it really
helps us PAX East is approaching we're
hoping to have some special guests maybe
a week or two coming in before that
anything for you we we are you know in
the early early things of scheduling a
community night so
it's early early like we got a date on
anything but I just figured out going in
and I'll just take that are either
patreon or that joining the realm you
guys are the one that addict will be
talking to and talking about oh and I
joke around with you know putting color
in chat that's a absolute joke I read a
lot of credit card stuff and we know but
I definitely appreciate every last one
of these people that are in here and yet
time is the currency that I love thank
you
Shalu 2g oh my boy G re no g37 forelock
day to build a stick-figure to better
look everybody show you something we are
out of here until next week